what's up everyone welcome to the video
today we're going to take a look at how
to replace the battery in this Honda
Pilot smart key remote fob this Honda
Pilot key fob is going to use
replacement battery CR
2032 and I'll put a link in the
description box of this video to where
you can find these replacement batteries
if you're in
need so the first thing I'm going to do
is grab my key fob and remove the
emergency key that's in the bottom of it
that's done by pressing this release on
the back of the fob that my thumb's on
and the key will pull out like that now
I'm going to use this key to open this
key fob case and I actually prefer to
use a flathead screwdriver it works a
little bit better but I'm going to show
you how to do it with just the key in
case that's all you have so taking a
look at the bottom of our key fob see
these two pieces right here that kind of
look like the letter e what I'm going to
do is take my key and put it in between
those two pieces like that then I'm just
going to
pry like that and as you can see it
opens the case and I'm holding the key
fob up like this for a better camera
angle but as you do this try to keep
your buttons facing down and that will
help keep them in
place so once we get that popped off
there go ahead and pull it the rest of
the way apart with your hands like that
now we see our battery right here and
I'm going to use this key to get under
the edge of the
battery and pop it out of that holder
and again for that part Works a flathead
screwdriver does work better for that as
well but once we get our old battery out
we can grab our new battery and we want
to make sure that we're installing our
new battery with the plus side up
positive side up and you want to tuck
that edge in
first like that and then snap it down
into place and we can snap the two
halves back
together slide our emergency key back in
and that's it if you could take a second
to like And subscribe it helps us out
and I'd appreciate it thank you